crybabies everyone is a bunch of
crybabies Oh Sakura it's so difficult
it's just like Dark Souls but much
harder it's like blood-borne / much
harder baby's pathetic children pathetic
beta males who don't know how to play
video games if you don't know you how to
use your fingers then don't even bother
playing video games I've been saying
this my entire life okay for those of
you who are new on this channel my name
is Peter PI and I'm a professional gamer
I have never died in a video game ever I
bet no one who's played this game knew
you could pick that letter up so feel
free to keep watching cuz we're gonna
find literally all the ins and outs see
I know how to jump in near jump wall
look at that I figured out already how
you all jump I bet no one ever figured
out how to wall jump so far I'm doing
extremely well zero deaths baby can we
add a deaf counter up in the corner wall
hug okay look at that see I don't even
need these patronizing instructions
because I know you see those scratches
on the wall that implies they put it
there as a hint even if there was no
scratches I wouldn't even need it okay
stealth what do you think I don't know
about stealth I'm the stealthiest man
and alive I'm the stealthiest person on
the gosh damn planet no one has ever
seen me that's how I behave no one's
ever done this you see this you hang
from the ledge because there's scratches
at the bottom
game developers put that in there I
don't even need it so good at games I'm
so gosh damn good at games zero that
yeah yeah zero bit yeah
look at that look at these moves
look at these goddamn moves so good at
games games is for children I'm playing
just to prove a point
games is for crybabies who think that
real life is too scary for them alright
give me the balls all right give me the
balls just give me the balls just give
me the balls I ain't got time quick
items here lean gourd all right let's do
the hidden boy epic shinobi Schinder ooh
all right watch this gamer washes gamers
attack oh wow charging it's fine what
that died that's it that's all it's all
anything shinobi gamers epic zero better
everyone zero deaths let's have some
juice my god this game is easy
oh god
deflection okay come on come on guy
don't think somebody there that I'm
actually really low in health I actually
need need some help watch this watch
this gamer that big stealth attack
coming right up
oh you just got ninja real ninjas travel
on the rooftop yeah barely made a sound
real shinobi's they move in the darkness
the darkness embraces [ __ ] they put that
there on purpose
they put that there on purpose oh shoot
gamers this could be it bye-bye gamers
by gamers zero deaths goes up another
one what is he doing oh he's bald he's
just walking backwards I'm right here
dude what he tanked it what the [ __ ]
what Nani what they usually get uh-huh
edit that out nine-year-old no one has
no one has to know
oh they can attack you while you're
doing it stuff what is this get up what
the hell was that this is not gamer
worthy look at that gamer moves little
bet do a good this is what it's like to
be watching a pro gamer in case you're
watching it doesn't get any more
interesting and epically than this
should we get that guy up there just for
the lulz no I can't be bothered ain't
get she no be jump ball drink edge
it's so easy come on come on I don't
even need to sell pathetic next one oh
god that guy looks tough
[Music]
is that alright so it's the first time I
explored this area so it better be
careful oh my god there's a guy there
what are the odds what are the odds
damn I would never have expected that
good thing I have top tier reflexes and
I know how to handle it I know how to
handle it because I'm a ninya linear
time it's much like on video if you are
ninja as well
watches ninja take down watched isn't in
yet take down ah
finger takedown yeah
what about what about me
I don't think so I don't think so hey
stop
[Music]
the wild uh terribly
Oh double this
I don't understand how the health works
[Music]
Oh up there
sorry Blanka
[Music]
oh okay I understand
so it's a posture system I didn't
understand how or why I thought he has
got his posture Meredith that's all you
had to do finish him
why is he not dying it was so easy
first try as well my god this game is
easy my god oh this game is so hard I
died on the first guy Wow you died on
the first guy Wow you must be a really
bad gamer if you died on the first try
luckily that was my first try so that
didn't happen to me I'm not a I'm an
actual gamer that knows how to play
video games I don't know about you but I
play video games not because I like to
not because I want to but because I'm so
goddamn good at them I'm so goddamn good
looking I'm so goddamn I'm a name yeah
the swedish ninja this is how we do it
in Sweden I've done it many times
look at that most people would go around
like a bad gamer I'm good gamer let me
tell you about good gaming you wouldn't
understand look at this first try first
try baby
what the hell is that not a bird a bird
alright bird if I know anything about
souls games is any threat that looks
simple it's actually quite difficult I
don't think that's a bird what is that
hello excuse me shinobi time shinobi
time
oh god you're ugly you're super ugly you
deserve to die my God look how ugly ugly
yeah so am I supposed to jump here to
there I ain't got time for that
drop down yeah okay drop that name come
on in yeah
alright so what are these helmets slowly
restores so far no dying has been made
if you see that if you're right if you
click ahead on the video you can see up
there I have 0 - set my probably should
have done this I just clicked for the
sake of clicking 0 this oh look it's 9
year old
god damn you're slow come on dude whoa
now this is an D me this reminded me of
the last boss in blood bar so cool this
is the first boss you're like it could
be how it is wow that's cool
[Music]
Wow he kicked me dude this is not going
great his posture is not going down
what what what happened aah my arm I
like that I masturbate with the right
one couldn't you have gotten the left
one yes I'm dead now is this one of
those bosses where you're supposed to
die you know I could actually kill him
even if oh he made a prosthetic awesome
oh this is so unrealistic back in the
shinobi days they didn't have any
personnel so she so so far zero deaths
cuz I didn't die back there so zero
deaths everyone all right so I can trade
stuff here I have okay oh you have a
grappling hook
what l2 what do you think I'm a gamer
that say that did my dudes zero that's
say it loud and clear
0 that 0 dude look at the aesthetic dude
man keep it so pretty
it gave me pretty very pretty game
grappling hook I'm a ninja I got sugar
[ __ ] but no one's ever found that no
one's ever done that
alright I ain't afraid some people would
probably try to sell them
that's what cowards do stealth in a
stealth game it's like shooting it's
like punching in a shooting game you're
not supposed to do it alright let's give
him some gamer fuel 10% off PewDiePie
autumn zero that's everyone this is not
how you're supposed to die you Madden
buying in that course that's just
humiliating I'm so sorry I did that to
you
all right let's grappling hook grappling
hook wow that was cool a lot of people
can't do that because they're not gamers
oh god who Tommy I I wasn't gonna do
with it I wasn't gonna do anything
alright grappling hook huh yeah he can
never come up here jump attack oh how is
that even possible
safe the roll safe the roll oh ah you
fell for the old safety role pathetic
all right give me your gamer loot dude
what don't shoot doggy oh did you kill
doggy
he killed dog and not through your ball
make [ __ ] up Fistful of ash dude why the
what a gamers die you know what I mean
honestly this game is a lot easier than
Dark Souls and blood-borne so far I mean
that genuinely not like a oh I'm so good
at games which I am oh god he's Tommy ah
ah go away go away go away bird go away
never come in the way of them
oh but she know me and he's blade than
his anger look how epic I am so good
zero that easy easy there girl aren't I
going all right that guy looks tough we
should probably know
I mean I will I will cuz I'm not a
coward like a lot of people would
probably go like oh I should probably
know that that game because it looks
really strong Nobi Nobi oh you see that
perfect landing oh oh perfect landing
huh
luggage oh he doubles strike okay
good old okay that one hurts okay I'm
starting to feel pain
Oh
what I can resurrect zero - yeah
but he slide my knees high
let's go for the gamer attack this time
that's a that's the gamer move first
fried beef
RESA rx0 that's yeah that's yeah that's
[Music]
let's go gamers how many deaths zero Oh
he shoots oh god there's so many come on
just come here just come here I ain't
good night
I got like someone's gonna are you
kidding me that was perfect
I don't think you would have learned
everywhere
no one sees me
I am the tree no one finds me I am the
invisible bush no one hears I'm too
silent
what is this alright let's start with
this guy cuz he took me over last time I
mean this is the first time I've done
this gamer
[Music]
anytime you set this stuff up I'm like
that has to be a trap here
hey there's no way they put it up these
easy but zero that said that thing
Oh God what the hell do they do shooting
ah they're shooting at me fine they
never hit lightning never pop ever just
gotta keep moving
[Applause]
don't like
zero nope don't think somebody my canon
my life yeah zero does Burt oh yeah
shinobi rest you know you might ask
yourself how is he so good at games
well I'm watched Naruto old episodes
even the filler ones that's right that's
how I embrace the ninja that's how I
grow to be this strong
[Music]
gamer fuel and that's how we came up
what the hell is this dude calm down
too much game with you need to relax
buddy oh alright it's okay he has to see
me okay let's go dude he's actually
blind alright let's just wait for the
right game he'll come
don't worry Felix he'll come [ __ ]
patient gamers are patient how are you
feeling kidding me
alright well then it will do it but
attack will sneak up on him now he turns
it around okay is he just gonna stay
there it's just gonna stay I think it
saw me okay he saw me
does he have a ranging
you can't hurt me from here
what's your battle plan Oh God he can
grab me yeah I don't want to get grabbed
[Music]
what what was happening what was that
are you kidding me
what is happened
[Music]
are you [ __ ] kidding me
zero that's all right
all right what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do write a big dick
what is that
miss me miss me you're not a gamer Oh
God what what I was that move what are
you doing
[Music]
what is that moon called
oh I don't like this guy
here have some hash
[Music]
dude he has two lives as well I don't
[Applause]
oh how you like that little ogre only
oniy
I know Japanese or you trying to take Oh
God are you kidding me
alright let's go for the dick all you
scared
I did not even hit me
[Music]
[Applause]
no kicks water fun
[Music]
what the running EcoPro dig Zack you got
the zigzag
[Music]
getting so gamer now are you kidding me
are you kidding me right now
this extra guy as well that's great
all right first time I do this all god
is an ogre I better start doing a lot of
damage while he's still contain oh god
no one's ever thought all the red stuff
that probably means he's about to it
[Music]
double-take
physics braking ogres
[Music]
and bipolar [ __ ]
Oh
[Music]
shut the [ __ ] up zero he sounds like
t-series crying
rival battle
oh I was so far away
shut the board
[Music]
dude I got a balloon
Oh God does he follow me into the fire
what sapphire doesn't do anything okay
cool good to know
I don't have time
[Music]
I hate that one
I'm not even fitting to play him just
sucking dick not that this is so easy
this game so far have not died a single
time zero birds did you see that gamers
can do that what the food is that camera
angle it looks like angry Santa Claus
I don't
it blades [ __ ]
they did not happen zero I clicked the
wrong button are you kidding me are you
kidding me stuck I'm not stuck I'm not
stuck
[Music]
[Applause]
no not the santa hug zero max I got the
same skill
zero Beckman
cool what am I supposed to do to dog
stay wait so can I grapple his thing
maybe I should try that
what does that cute boy raffle him I can
grapple him why did no one say so I
can't do anything if you dust that
literally what am I supposed to do okay
first try guys whoo all right so far
this game has been pretty easy and
pretty underwhelming I don't understand
why anyone calls difficult it's my god
it's so easy it's just so easy it's just
so can't seem easy
all right so oh look there's an over
there all right no idea I have no idea
No oh yeah jump into him that will do
the trick get up
what is the point of the graph
[Music]
[Applause]
I can't do anything don't understand
like a donor saying someone explain to
me how am I supposed to dodge they
instead pinky L button No
what is night no goddammit he was almost
there
oh my god he threw me off are you
getting back alright so first time we're
doing this sure what the heck
all right easy does he get hard then
what did you say that are you kidding me
0:03
are you overboard why are you getting
again are you [ __ ] kidding me
you see the animation he goes and then
oh he's a minute what the [ __ ] is that
oh I'm sorry
that I know so much get enough pink
dodge come at me bro I wasn't even in
there but okay
don't think so my bro don't think so
sometimes I'm gonna do this what is that
dude
[Applause]
yes
don't think so
don't think so oh you're gonna hug me
Santa doesn't like hugs no not that one
not official zero zero
how many times to indict Sarah I never
do it never do it mover Saint that day
Saint that ball you're gone you gone
[ __ ] you going you gonna know go [ __ ]
oh look I didn't need to use the club
they are you died your buddy easy so
easy my god how easy that was oh this
game is supposed to be hard
oh really
then how is that so easy
[Music]
zero yard